que christophe crépin porte parole du
syndicat france police
bonjour et merci d'être en direct par
téléphone avec nous sur rt france quelle
est votre réaction sur ce qui s'est
passé ce week end
aujourd'hui la france est en train de
lutter contre un ennemi invisible d'un
virus qui fait de nombreux morts le
gouvernement demande aurait été confiné
à domicile des gens qui habitent dans
les banlieues fond ce que l'on recouvre
le gouvernement leur demande ils sont
vraiment très disciplinés à la côte à
côte et de faire nous avons des
individus dans des banlieues qui vivent
de commerce qui vivent deux mondes
parallèles et qui appelle les forces de
l'ordre at elle également est confiée
mettre le feu comme ils ont l'habitude
de le faire pour créer des
problématiques quand mes collègues
interviennent avec les pompiers
rappellent que les pompiers sont en
première ligne à contrôler virus ils
caillassent les pompiers ils tirent sur
les collègues et ce n'est pas un fait
anodin ce n'était pas un fait isolé
c'est un fait dans beaucoup de banlieues
je pense qu'aujourd'hui il va falloir
que notre ministre de l'instruction pour
qu'on puisse lutter identifié des
individus les interpeller et mettre à
disposition des tic en comparution
immédiate
à vous entendre à l'origine de ces
violences ce week-end il ya donc ce
qu'on signaux qui empêche le trafic des
stupéfiants c'est ce que vous pensez
bien que je pense de la missive qui est
faut bien comprendre que là des gens qui
économisent parallèle toutes les
familles vivent de cette économie
il faut aux façons les identifions les
connais mes collègues aux stups lee 93
pour un travail que je sais ça ferait
bien qu'attristé l'individu
maintenant il faut donner les
instructions de faire pour aller
chercher les gens ils ne sont pas
d'accord pour faire vivre les valeurs de
la république est ce qu'aujourd'hui on
doit tous faire front vers sept-îles mis
à visite qui est le corps navires us et
aussi les mettre à disposition d'un
suicide qui pendra dépollution évident à
la lutte avec les individus qui
faisaient la une bani dans ses banlieues
mais pour le même prix mais ce soir
emmanuel apprendre à s'exprimer ce soir
s'il veut prolonger comme c'est très
vraisemblable le confinement est ce que
vous craignez que d'autres incidents de
ce type se déroulent à nouveau
les prochaines semaines qu'est ce que
vous me parlez de cluny
mais il n'ya pas que rêver il ya
beaucoup d'endroits en france où des
individus qui avaient l'habitude de
semer la zizanie de ce mais aussi leurs
portes à eux dans des banlieues se
trouve fort du canal + puis deux heures
tragiques qui gangrène la france
merci beaucoup d'avoir pris le temps de
répondre à nos questions christophe
crépin porte parole du syndicat france
police